now the third day of supreme court
nomination hearings for judge katanji
brown jackson took place on capitol hill
judge jackson was once again pressed on
her record surrounding allegations of
being very lenient and lenient
sentencing for child porn offenders
here's an exchange with senator josh
hawley of missouri take a look
the government asked for enhancements
related to prepubescent children related
to the the nature of these images you
say i'm not going to apply it but what
you're telling me is i guess that you
you don't have a policy objection why
why didn't you apply the enhancements as
they were asked for senator i've
answered this question many times from
many senators who've asked me so i'll
stand on what i've already said
so you have nothing to add about about
why these crimes why these images in
your view
do not signal an especially heinous or
egregious child pornography offense
here with reaction senator josh hawley
senator one one interesting part of that
exchange you asked uh judge jackson
why she actually in one case apologized
to convicted a convicted pedophile at
sentencing why would you ever apologize
to a convicted pedophile and you're
still not given the maximum sentence to
or even the recommended sentence or what
the prosecutors wanted
yeah in fact what she gave that
convicted criminal sean was three months
three months he was eligible for up to
10 years in prison she gave him three
months and she apologized to him i mean
listen we've had now over 20 hours of
questioning in the judiciary committee
and i think her record is pretty clear
when it comes to crime and especially
crimes against children this is somebody
who apologizes to the criminals this is
someone who has handed out one lenient
sentence after another especially when
it comes to these child sex crimes and
frankly this is somebody who i just
can't support for people that that maybe
didn't have time all day to watch the
hearings on this particular issue which
you brought to the nation's attention
first uh there are a number of factors
in play here and one is the
recommendation of the prosecutors that
got guilty conv got convictions in these
cases that she wouldn't listen to the
prop prosecutors recommendation for
sentencing uh nor would she go along
with federal guidelines guidelines for
sentencing and she was extraordinarily
lenient in almost every case i didn't
see a case where she wasn't yeah 100
percent of the time sean i mean that's
the deal she has had multiple just to
take one set of crimes multiple child
porn crime offenses and in every single
case that she has had of child porn
offenses she's sentenced below what the
prosecutor wanted she's sentenced below
what the national guidelines are every
time 100 of the time and she just can't
explain it i mean we tried to ask her
day after day hour after hour she has no
explanation for it and i think the
american people watching this are saying
listen i want somebody who's going to
protect children who's going to be tough
on child criminals people who go after
children and not apologize to them i
mean why would she apologize to the
criminal i just don't understand it she
gave a speech at michigan's law school
and in that speech
she seemed to support the 16-19 project
in critical race theory but listening to
her answers to you and others on the
committee you would think that you know
she never said those things to those
students in the law school
yeah she said that she didn't know
anything about critical race theory
despite the fact that she has praised it
and said that it's part of what she does
in sentencing i mean listen it's just
this is a person who is a leftist and
you know that's fine those are her views
i mean she comes by him honestly they're
just not ones that i agree with and i
can just tell you i can't vote for
somebody on the u.s supreme court who's
going to apologize to criminals who is
not going to be tough when you need to
be tough in order to protect children
and i just you've got to be able when
the time comes to say listen if you are
a child predator you are going to jail
for a long time and that's something she
just hasn't been willing to do how is it
that she says that every judge she
believes has a hidden agenda that that
struck me as particularly odd i'd like
to think that we have an independent
judiciary that believed in separation of
powers co-equal branches of government
and that would uphold the law of the
land based on our constitution um
not go by
you know whatever their hidden agenda is
have you figured out our hidden agenda
well i think that her agenda is based on
her beliefs and i think her beliefs are
pretty clear she thinks that the
criminal justice system is too hard on
criminals and she thinks in particular
that those who commit child sex offenses
child porn offenders that the criminal
justice system is too hard on them
that's why she apologizes to them that's
why she 100 percent of the time
sentences sentences them less than the
prosecution wants or the guidelines and
you know i just think at the end of the
day sean every senator now is going to
have to make a decision because every
senator is going to have to vote on this
and put their dime down and i for one am
going to vote no
i think that's the proper vote for any
republican i'm sure mitt romney will
vote yes and
apparently even lisa murkowski in an
election year oddly will probably vote
no
we'll see though